hello everyone and welcome to my
presentation javascript powered smart
home with
almost no code so today i'm going to
talk a lot about iot devices i'm going
to talk a little bit about code but
mostly i'm going to talk about how you
can avoid doing code
not that as software developers that's
actually what we usually want to do we
usually like to write some code but
sometimes there are shortcuts that are
really nice to use so let's start by
talking a little bit about iot devices
and why should we care about them i mean
sure we've all heard about different
internet connected things
but i don't know if you've ever realized
the amount of iot devices that are
available out there it is actually
expected by 2025 there will be 75
billion devices that will be working and
will be connected to the internet that
is a lot of devices and i was looking at
that graph and i was thinking how is
that even possible so i charted with the
world population try to see if the world
population followed the same trend and
and not at all i mean it's just that we
tend to have more and more devices
as a matter of fact i i looked at the
number of current devices which is
around 50 billion and divided that by
their current world population and that
gave me something like six devices per
person
like there's no way i have six connected
devices in my home
so i started thinking a little bit okay
well first of all i i've got i've got
two
laptops we've got a laptop for the
family my wife has her own laptop so
that's four connected devices uh of
course we each have our our cell phones
um and this is you know a household of
two
uh we each have a tablet now
some people might argue that those are
not iot devices they're connected to the
web but they're not iot things per se so
i started thinking okay well do i have
any
connected devices well i i certainly
have a thermostat um
oh right i've got my smoke detectors so
i've got two of them
i've got oh i've got a smart tv which is
also connected on the internet i've got
well i've got some smart bulbs
which i'll get back to that they're not
that great
i've got some connected plugs i've got
three of them i actually use them to
turn on and off my christmas lights and
various things outside and i've got
connected speakers so my speakers are
connected to the internet so that they
can stream music and all right my home
assistants i've got a bunch of those
around the house and so i've got three
of them
my door locks i've got yeah front door
and back door they both have smart locks
in there and and and i have a vacuum an
internet connected vacuum because well
you know everybody wants to start the
vacuum when they're not at home so
i started counting at that and that's
like um
18 devices that's nine per person so i
guess for someone who thought i didn't
have that many i still do have a lot of
them
so iot devices why should you care well
probably because they're all over the
place and and you probably have a bunch
of them at home and in your professional
career there's a fairly good chance that
at some point you'll actually have to
deal with some iot devices
so this is what i'm going to talk about
today so hi my name is joel i work as a
developer advocate for mongodb if you
ever want to get in touch with me
twitter is always always always the best
way so joel underscore underscore
there's 200 scores there
so joel underscore underscore lord is
the way to reach me um you know just to
talk about anything whether it's
databases um
connected devices or just to say hi
if you've enjoyed this presentation feel
free to tweet i always appreciate a
twitter notification
so before we get started and before we
jump into our actual topic i just wanted
to let you know and and just to take a
second to talk about this i'm a hacker i
like to tinker with stuff i have a bunch
of little
connected sensors and and various micro
microprocessors that i i just enjoyed
that type of stuff but i've never worked
on a professional project with them so
whatever i'm going to say here those are
my opinion
i mean there's definitely
probably most likely better ways to do
things than what i'm going to introduce
but if you want to hack around and play
around i think that um there's a lot of
the content that you'll find here that
can actually be interesting
speaking of content this is what i'm
going to cover today so i'm going to
talk about iot and javascript so how can
we use javascript to
build iot stuff and connect devices to
the world so we're going to look at the
at that um typically we've always we
tend to think about c plus plus to build
embedded stuff but it turns out that you
can actually do pretty a lot of cool
stuff with javascript i'm going to talk
about localed interfaces as well low
code is kind of a trending thing we see
more and more of those interfaces where
you don't actually need to code
and finally i'm going to introduce you
to iot and low code so i'm going to show
you how i've managed to solve a few of
my problems around my home by using both
some iot devices and some local
interface
so iot and javascript just like pb and j
as i mentioned already we don't always
think of javascript as the main language
to program various devices that will
connect to the internet we tend to think
of c plus plus typically but it turns
out that you can do a lot of things as a
matter of fact just a few years ago i
was at a presentation where i had the
privilege of presenting this tiny robot
that was controlled by a kinect sensor
that you can see right there it gets my
skeleton and i can do gestures and and
the robot would fly off
so i was able to do all of that using
javascript so all the the kinect sensor
the detection of gestures the actual
little robot there
everything in there is all built with
javascript
let's see that again
there it goes
okay so getting started how do you get
started and start programming different
devices using javascript well i'm going
to talk about mainly two different
devices that you can use for iot to get
to get started at the espirino and the
raspberry pi
the esprino is this tiny little
device right there that you can see
it's based on the arduino open hardware
a few years back we talked a lot about
the arduino there were ways to use the
arduino board javascript but that wasn't
really easy the esprino really you can
use javascript out of the box on the
micro controller it uses the esp esp8266
chip that is a programmable micro
controller that also has a wi-fi
connection on it
so this tiny devices goes for about 35
canadian dollars i think at the moment
so you get them for pretty cheap and and
you can do some really powerful stuff
with that
so the esprino wi-fi is the one that
i've just shown you is a tiny usb and
wi-fi enabled microcontroller that can
be programmed in javascript so just plug
it into your computer and get started in
seconds with the web id no software
installation needed so that's from the
esprino website
you can find out more information there
and that's actually one of the places
where you can actually get your devices
so this is what the ide looks like so
you can actually there's a website you
can just go to that website and then in
theory you should be able to connect to
your sensor
now this one is running inside my
presentation so inside and iframes so it
gets a little bit tricky but i actually
have the um
the
ide right here right in the back
there it is and i've got this little
code that will just blink a lead i've
got a little tiny microcontroller right
here that you can see let me just make
that a little bit bigger so you've got a
microcontroller here so what i can do
from this ui i can actually connect i
can connect to my esprino board
there we've got it i'm missing a
semicolon here thank you id
and now i can flash my device now that i
flash the device in just a few seconds
you should see the led starting to blink
pretty cool isn't it yeah so there it is
and then we also have the status so you
can see that right there in the ide the
status being updated on whether the
press d led is on or off
so that's a very tiny little example
that's kind of the hello world of iot
devices um of course i wanted to build
some things a little bit more complex
and we've got here um i you might have
noticed that i i do have something
connected to it which is this tiny
sensor right here it's a temperature
sensor
and if i just go ahead and um of course
i won't write all of the code for it but
i'll just copy and paste this code right
here
and i can flash my device again so next
time that it starts it will actually
have that code on it
and what this will do is i will actually
connect to my wi-fi
and it will um now you have my wi-fi
password there it is
and and it will start making a call to a
a ui so to a url so this url right here
and i'll get back to that in just a few
minutes so now what it's doing is that
it's actually just getting the
temperature and humidity levels and just
sense that over the uh wi-fi connection
all right so let's take a look at the
original code that i've shown you so
this is the blank so the hello world of
iot devices is always a blinking led
usually there's a led available on board
that you can use that is true for most
little microprocessor micro controllers
that you have access to as well as the
raspberry pi's or some versions of
so the other microcontroller that you
can use is the raspberry pi and i
actually have one right here i'm not
sure if it will
let me just disconnect now i want
disconnected because
it does take a few minutes to reboot but
this is actually the actual picture of
my raspberry pi
so that's the raspberry pi 4 which was
just released recently and raspberry
pi's are actually a tiny dual display
desktop computer and robot brains smart
home hub media center network ai core
factory controller and much more so
that's also from the raspberry pi
website
but basically what the raspberry pi is
is that it's a tiny computer on a board
um and it's it's tiny it's about this
this big uh you know it's it's very very
small and it's very powerful that that
little uh device has eight gigabyte of
rams um it has like a hard drive that
you can add afterwards it uses an sd
card for that
so it's a tiny computer that you can use
and it has a bunch of little pins that
you can use and connect devices on them
or sensors or different things so in the
case of my tiny device here i've
actually plugged a led on it and um and
let's actually take a look at some of
the code
so in order to be able to oh and another
interesting thing and let me actually
show you the ui very quickly um so this
is
my raspberry pi and it's connected right
now and you can see that it's it's it's
a computer it runs linux it runs a
version of debian
and it actually has node.js
pre-installed on it
it actually has a bunch of little tools
that you can use but you can see here
that i have a terminal window and i can
actually use it to do some different
things like i can edit some code this is
my blinking code i'll come back to the
actual code in here in just a few
minutes but then i can actually run this
code and run this oops not this one but
i can run my node.js application and it
will just start blinking my lead pretty
much similar to what i did with the
esprino as well
so in order to be able to program on
your raspberry pi you will need two
libraries you'll need johnny five um you
actually don't need johnny but it does
make your life a lot easier
and raspy io or raspio that will be used
to control the different pins on your
raspberry pi
the code that i've just shown you in my
in my terminal was exactly this code so
first of all you require the john 5
library required you rest by and then
you just initialize a new board
now it's an event
event driven
type of programming so you'll have
events like board on ready this tells
you that the board is initialized and
ready to use and once it's ready i can
initialize or declare a new led so by
using the pin number then i can use the
method blink and it will just start
blinking my lid
all right so what should you use an
esprino or raspberry pi well they're
both pretty cool actually they're both
pretty amazing little devices but they
do have some very different use cases
the esprino is great for being tiny tiny
tiny and just i can just easily connect
a little sensor on it and there you go i
can just put that
i can connect the battery on it and just
throw it somewhere and forget about it
and it just works and it's very very
power efficient and so i can just forget
about it the raspberry pi on the other
hand not as an energy efficient it's
actually a full computer if you need to
access it well you'll need to connect a
you know a keyboard on it then you'll
need to connect the display on it
but it can be very useful if you want to
build a media center then you can
actually use that raspberry pi and then
you can use those external pins for
additional sensors or to
you know add different little things to
it
so it really depends on your use cases
but you know both of them can be very
useful
all right so i've talked about iot
devices now let's talk about the low
code movement what is exactly is low
code or sometimes called no code
well local development platform provides
a development environment used to create
application software through graphical
user interface instead of traditional
hand-coded computer programming
a local platform may produce entirely
operational applications or require
additional coding for specific
situations enabling accelerated delivery
of business applications
all right so why should we care right
we're software developers we know how to
code so why should we care about low
code interfaces
well there's there's a few good reasons
for that mainly you don't want everybody
to rely on you as a software developer
all the time right so sometimes you can
use local interfaces to make it easier
for
for other people in your team that are
not as technical savvy to be able to
contribute to your project
so you using a local interface you can
give access to
some sort of reporting tool to your
managers and then they'll be able to
just you know add new sources of
incoming data and then they'll be able
to
generate new charts and stuff
so local interfaces can be very very
useful for that type of thing
but it can also be really helpful when
you're building iot
iot ecosystems and and you you need
different interface and you don't want
to build everything from scratch every
time so there's a lot of tooling that
you can actually use to help you with
that i'm going to talk about two here
there's a lot more um ifttt is a product
that is available really made for makers
it's really really simple to use
and i'm going to talk about node-red
which is a project that i've recently
discovered and i think it's an amazing
product and definitely worth talking
about
so ifttt helps all of your apps or helps
all of your apps and devices work better
together it makes it easy to build
applets connecting various services
so you can find out more information on
ifttt.com
but what does it mean well basically
you've got if this then that so that's
the ifttt so you can just create connect
a bunch of different services so you can
say things like well if i've got a new
follower on twitter then start vacuuming
so
and and that's actually uh that's
actually running on on my ifttt account
so you know if you want to follow me on
twitter you'll help me to have a clean
floor because it'll start my robot
but most of the time it's actually a fun
thing so i just know that i have a new
follower when the vacuum starts so you
can see the type of
services that then there's a lot of
different services that you can connect
to
and you can see how you can just
integrate each one of them together and
create some of those flows
the other one that i wanted to talk
about and actually just before i leave
let me just switch back here
not here but
i actually had my little tiny little
device here which is probably still
running
i don't have any oh yep yet i just saw
that link so in in a minute it will do
another readout on my temperature sensor
and it's actually connected to ifttt as
well
and i forgot to put it so let me just
push this window right here and every
time that it gets a new event every time
it detects a new temperature so every
minute or so it actually inputs a new
data a new row in here so i can actually
see that the temperature right now is 27
degrees it's a little bit hot here today
that's celsius
and 45 humidity
and if we wait and if i just you know
talk a little bit a little more and i'm
not sure what i'm going to say but in
just a few minutes you should see
another row being added because it'll do
another um another reading
every minute
should we wait
there it is coming
meh let's just leave it there
i'll put it in the background so we
might be able to see it
in just a few seconds
all right so let's talk about no red no
red is a programming tool for wiring
together hardware devices apis and
online services in new and interesting
ways it provides a browser-based editor
that makes it easy to wire together
flows using a wide range of nodes in the
palette that can be deployed in a
runtime in a single click
all right nodered.org you'll find more
information there by the way
i was very excited but i didn't want to
start reading but you saw that i got a
new reading while i was reading this
this little presentation here
okay so back to my presentation
note red how can you get started with
node red well if you have docker
installed it's actually very easy you
just run this command and you're good to
go so it starts a web server on port
1880 and it will have node red installed
and ready to be
used so what is node-red well this is
the ui so if you are running and i'm
actually running it in docker right now
and so you can see that i have it on
localhost 1880
what can we do with that well there's a
lot of things that we can do so first of
all let's start with the basic hello
world type of thing so we can inject
something
i'll try to make this a little bit
bigger so there you go um and then i'm
gonna use a debug statement so
a little bit like uh you know when we do
console logs when we're trying to do
some javascript programming we want to
see what's going on we can use the debug
right here so we've got those two nodes
i can link them together
and let's actually change here so we
won't send a timestamp we'll actually
send a json object we can use the visual
editor so say i'm not you know very
familiar with json or
javascript programming so i can say okay
well we'll send a a message
and the message will be
hello world
there you go so i'm gonna send a message
hello world and in here i'm going to
debug the payload so i've got my
debugger up and running so right here
you should see messages let's deploy
this application there it is
um missing twitter credentials
ignore that for late for now
but we can see that whenever i
trigger this this little node here so i
can click on the button and we get the
message hello world being displayed
pretty cool isn't it
well
okay well maybe it's not that cool but
but there's a lot of things that we can
do with that
we could say well okay let's change this
and say um
we will trigger hello and and we'll add
another field so let's use the visual
editor again because i think it's pretty
cool actually let's just use the json
and uh we'll we'll you know person will
be joel
uh so now we can send this object and we
can still trigger it let's just deploy
this again
we can trigger it and we get this new
json object so you can see that there's
a little bit more information in it
so that's good so far but we can add a
switch
and now with my switch statement i can
connect this to my switch and i can say
well if it's equal to
jaw
you know
output to node 1 and
anything else so if it's different from
joel
do something else
and let's not use message.payload but
message.payload.person right here okay
so now this should be triggered let's
remove
this link here i'll add my debugger at
the end and in another case we will
create a function
and let's open this we will change the
message we'll say message.payload
equals
message
you are not dull
okay so i've got this new payload and
now i'm going to output this as well to
the same node right here
so if the person is dual it's going to
output directly the exact payload and if
it's not then i'm gonna output some
other message so let's deploy this
application there it is let's click on
this hello world this worked let's
actually change the name of the person
to
um someone else someone
else
there you go redeploy the application
and boom you are not dual so there you
go so you can start to create those
those
more complex flows and you can start to
add some conditional statements and so
on
another interesting thing that you can
do is that you can actually go to manage
palette here and you can search for
different things so say you want to
connect to twitter well you can actually
go to twitter and add the
node red twitter
node
so that's a node that enables you to
talk to twitter
as you've seen i already have it
installed but my credentials are not
valid here
if you want to connect to a mongodb
database well you can use the
the one right here
which is installed and it's a node to
communicate with a [ __ ] database which
is pretty interesting as well so we can
actually go in here
and i don't know if you you know if you
want to give access to someone to your
application or to build applications and
you want to show them how to
uh
or you need to show them how to connect
to a database i mean that that can be
complicated what i'm going to do here is
i'm going to add a insert operation on
my [ __ ] database which is already
configured
in the collection flow data
so there it is and now uh whatever is
the payload of my message i'm actually
going to just send the payload directly
into my database and that should add a
new statement to my database so let's
deploy this we can see that we're
connected and now if i trigger this this
whole
flow we can see that it worked and if i
show you i actually have an interface to
manage my um
[ __ ] database right here
and we we can see that uh you know we've
just got our pay that was added right
here as a message person someone else as
i just typed and if i change the
inject here to actually say hello to
joel instead there you go
redeploy this application
retrigger this application and we should
be able to see a new entry right there a
hello world person
tool
cool so you can start programming your
your applications and and maybe you
start to see where this can get really
really powerful so it's really easy to
integrate a lot of different services
together into this this application so
i'm already able to you know add some
information into a database do some
conditional statements and all of that
in just a few minutes
on on a graphical interface
all right but um the whole thing the
whole goal and one of the things that
really led me to this presentation was
i have some
smart devices in my network but
they're not really that smart i've
already hinted at my smart bulbs and
there's a few cases so i i wanted i
wondered if i could make things a little
bit smarter by using those technologies
so you know some of the problems that i
have the thermostat temperature is kind
of inconsistent well not that it's
inconsistent but it's in the middle of
the hallway and when we sleep at night
well you know i like to keep the
temperature a little bit lower but i
want to measure the temperature in the
room not in the middle of the hallway
my my smart bulbs they're great um but i
actually have to open up my phone and
press on on or off which is
kind of annoying i'd rather have a
switch in that case i managed to connect
it to my home assistants which this
definitely makes it easier but you know
what if we could make that a little bit
smarter
my air exchanger i've got these big huge
devices device that uh exchanged the air
but it's a stupid device actually
there's a switch that i need to flick to
on or high you know or off so
not that great so i wondered if i could
make that a little bit smarter and of
course my plans they're not connected to
the internet so i figured what if i
could actually do that
well let's go back to our node-red
interface here uh so first of all for my
thermostat what i what i did here is
that i actually have
exactly this type of device so i've got
my esp or my esprino connected to a
temperature sensor and it just sends the
temperature every minute or so to my
temperature sensor or to my uh to my
node right here so that's an http it
creates an http endpoint that i can
actually ping
and then i'll check for the hour so it's
if it's you know during night time um
then it will actually move on or check
the time and if it's not during night
time it just ignore ignores the the
request but if it is it'll check the
current temperature and based on the
temperature that the sensor picked up
it'll either turn on or off
so it'll set the value one or zero and
then it will send an outgoing request to
another web service and of course i want
to save that into my [ __ ] database as
well
so you can see that i've just created
this whole flow and now thanks to this
tiny little device that was programmed
in javascript and this little flow that
i've just shown you i can now control
the temperature based on uh depending on
the time of the day and i can actually
pick up the temperature in my room
instead
for my lights um well i i didn't really
care about turning them on or off what i
wanted really was to and their exterior
lights so i wanted to base that on the
sunset so i've added this little note
here sun event inject and this actually
happens whenever there's a sunset it
deploys or it triggers this event i wait
for an hour because i want about an hour
after sunset where it's really dark then
turn on the lights and i use this
trigger node here which will
which is really cool it'll actually
trigger something and then it will wait
for four hours and then it will trigger
another event so the first time it has a
one the second time it has a zero and
then i'm able to send an http request to
my service that controls my lights
using ifttt and it will turn it on or
off based on the value that i've just
sent it of course same thing also save
that into my database so i can actually
see what was happened it helps me to
debug when i see or noticed that oh the
lights didn't turn on yesterday or
things like that
my air exchanger so i added a tiny
little um relay on it so i'm actually
able to turn it on or off now
and now i use an interval so every every
hour i started for about 20 20 minutes
i do that only during daytime so i don't
want to do it at night because it's kind
of noisy so i do my check time as well
it's similar to what i did earlier i
triggered for 20 minutes and i just sent
the http request to my little relay that
i have plugged on my device
now if i have a or not if but i do have
a little
air quality sensor as well that i have
in my kitchen so if i burn something the
theory is that but it never happens
right so
but if i do the theory is that it will
actually send a request right here um to
this bad air url and that will actually
trigger another 20 minute of my air
exchanger so it will automatically clean
the air in my kitchen
and what else do i have well of course
my plants i wanted to know when to water
my plants so i've added a little
hydrometer that i put in with a nesprino
um i i changed the range so it sends me
a value from 0 to 1024 or 23 i change
that from zero to 100 and they then
based on uh the critical amount of water
that it needs whether it's under 25 or
under 10
it'll actually either send me an email
or send me a tweet because i
you know i'm more often on twitter than
i am on my emails
so it actually sends me a tweet when
it's it gets critical
and then i save this event to my
database again so you can see how i can
connect all those different services i
can send emails connect to twitter and
there's a lot a lot lot different things
that you can do with node node red and
that's just you know a little preview of
what it can do
so iot and javascript can you use iot
with javascript or javascript with iot
devices well turns out that you can it
actually works out really really well
it's nice because i don't have to learn
a new language i don't have to learn
anything new i can just use my current
knowledge and immediately start
programming iot devices
local interfaces really fun for a lot of
different things if you want to you know
make it a little bit easier for
different people to be able to add and
contribute to your projects then that's
definitely a good way to go but it's
actually a lot easier as well than to
have to program all of it so iot and low
code they go well together especially
that this one is really event based so
it waits for
incoming http requests and things it
just works so well with the whole iot
ecosystem so this is what i had for
today so thank you very much for
attending this was my talk javascript
power smart home with almost no code
there's a little bit but not too much
thank you very much for being here and
if you want more information easy url to
slash js no code and you can find me on
twitter at joel underscore underscore
lord thank you very much